If you wanna get rid of your allergies,
this is the hack for you. Realistically,
I think this is the only thing I can thank my ex for.
Cause ever since she got me hooked on this stuff,
I haven't been sick once. To the point where I just ordered 3 new jars
cause I don't ever wanna be out of this stuff.
I'm never sick and it's completely taking my allergies away.
This is superfood honey.
I didn't know there was different grades of honey,
but this is literally medical honey.
And if you do any research on bees,
you see that the queen bee rise on this stuff.
When I heard medical honey,
I wanted to be safe, so I asked my doctor about it
and he said he's been taking a spoonful of this stuff every single day
himself. And just like me,
he said him and his family are never sick
and their allergies are completely gone.
So with it being spring and everything blooming,
I'm definitely taking an extra spoonful every single day.
You want to get rid of your allergies,
this is the hack for you.
The only problem I have with this stuff is since it's such high grade,
it's always going out of stock.
So if you see the orange shopping cart below,
it's still available. I would grab it while you can.